hi i'm dorothy natsuke the chief medical
officer at bioshock
and research assistant professor at suny
downstate health science university
today i'm going to talk about emerging
technologies that can help us to use as
precision infectious disease diagnostic
such as next generation sequencing and
artificial intelligence
so today i'm going to talk about what we
do at bioshock precision infectious
disease diagnostic
and using clinical metagenomics to
identify pathogens
and antimicrobial resistance we use next
generation sequencing and
i'm going to show a couple of examples
how we can implement this into the
husker
and since everything shifted during the
last couple of months
to focus on code 19 i'm going to talk
about how next generation sequencing can
be used in genomic epidemiology
and diagnostic as well so my background
is actually
pediatrics and after medical school and
graduating
from the summerwest university i joined
the texas children's hospital
as a clinical research scientist to
focus on pediatric
chronic gastrointestinal disorders very
early on i was introduced to the
microbiome concept
the trillions of bacteria living in our
body and how we can use them
understand them and use them for
diagnostic and also for therapeutics
after texas student hospital i earned my
phd in clinical metagenomics
and joined the columbia university
center for infection and immunity
to work with one of the most established
biologists
ia to use next generation sequencing
and use this technology for infectious
disease diagnostics not only for a good
but also for
chronic disorders two years ago i joined
bioshock
with the mindset to bring this novel
technology to the husker and help
for patients every day to use this small
snowball technology
in infectious disease diagnostic so
our mission at bioshock is to fight
infectious disease by providing
precision diagnostics
and deploying the leading global genomic
database
of microbes and antimicrobial resistance
markers
so we have an incredible team with our
co-founders dr
nev o'hara and dr christopher mason
the pioneer in advancing precision
infectious disease diagnostic
we have a clear laboratory in new york
state and developed novel clinical
microbiome
um interestingly we made microbes from
the new york subway
to hospitals we have one of the largest
databases of hospital-acquired
infections
collaborated with nasa and built a
leading software for identification of
pathogens
so what's the problem we try to track
all there is a high diagnostic failure
that means that
18 million diagnostic errors happen
annually
and there is a limitation with the gold
standard technologies such as
sculpturing and pcr that the hospitals
are using currently
and that can lead to misdiagnosis
also with that there is an increased
mortality without diagnosis and proper
antibiotic therapy
another problem is that when we don't
know what we are
have to treat we use frequently broad
spectrum antibiotics
and that means that there is an
increased risk for resistance and
dangerous side effect profile
also in infectious disease one of the
most crucial point is time
we need rapid targeted treatment that
can
increase survival and shorten the
hospital stay
stay with a decreased cost for both the
hospitals and the patients
and i really like to show this slide to
show that like how emerging uh
global crisis is anti-microbial
resistance by 2050 they predict that
around 10 million people are going to
die annually
from an infection that cannot be treated
by antibiotics
so there is an increased need for
emerging technologies to identify the
pathogen the antimicrobial resistance so
we can guide the physicians how to treat
these patients and some of the examples
of the corporate
i just highlighted a couple of high
priority pathogens
that can be identified in patients and
hospital surfaces such as
asynaptobacter bomboni pseudomonas
aeruginosa
these are all carbopranal resistant
pathogens
which can highly prevalent in hospitals
and
in patients but also we know there is an
emerging of
staphylococcus aureus and enterobacter
species
or the crocidius cluster diodes
difficile
which are highly resistant to different
antibiotics
so just to show you a couple of numbers
what we have to deal every day um in the
infectious disease boards uh almost half
of the patients uh
we cannot tell a definitive diagnosis
but the pathogens there what needs to be
treated
that means that uh usually there's a
very high number for empiric antibiotic
therapies
for these patients so what's the
current gold standard method is
culturing which is actually a technology
from the 1800s
which is very limited targeted you need
to know what the pathogen you want to
identify it's very labor intensive and
low throughput
so what we have been trying to use is
next generation sequencing when you
have the whole microbial composition
um of a sample uh it's very
comprehensive and it can be high
throughput
we use two technologies oxford
nanoforming ion which is like a
deployable
small equipment that
the advantage that it can be used
offshore not just in hospitals and
illumina sequencer which is like more
accepted in clinical diagnostics
so what exactly is sequencing um it's an
important tool for mapping of genomes of
novel and known
organisms and compare genomes across
multiply samples
and also it's being used for discovery
characterization
and identification of the microbes
so how it's actually happening in a
laboratory we collect the samples
which could be any kind of human sample
type
urine stores cerebrospinal fluid we can
call it environmental samples
and since we are focusing on the
microbiogenetic information
we usually do pre-processing of lysine
the human cells
digest the human dna so we end up with
only the microbial stars
then we do microbial dna or rna
extraction
and then use library preparation which
can
cut up the genetic information identify
them
and amplify and we use sequencing to
have all these genetic information in a
comprehensive matter
from each and every sample it can be
multiplexed and many samples can run
together that
that can efficiently improve the highest
throughput
and also decrease the cost we have
bioinformatic pipelines built out
for processing the data and analyzing
the information
so at columbia university previously at
the center for infection immunity
i was privileged to work with incredible
groups
who have been developing capture
sequencing that means that focusing on
the viruses or the bacteria we can
amplify
those genetic information which can
improve the sensitivity
and we have been working with also
unbiased metagenomics that
can describe novel uh pathogens
and infectious disease agents and this
was quite interesting to
have clinical samples when we had no
known origin and we were able to find
the pathogen by using
net generation sequencing
so what made us possible to use this
technology the sequencing
cost dramatically dropped during the
last
years and also the computational
advances
using bioinformatics tools dealing with
large
data set and using artificial
intelligence provided us and enabled
to use this technology and after we have
the sequencing and genetic information
we can quickly process these data sets
and use it
to provide a report for the physicians
and why is it so important it's actually
not just only in acute infectious
diseases but
there was a paper early this year that
showed that
in chronic diseases there is a high
predictive power
of the microbiome the microbial
composition from one body type
that can actually associated with
different chronic diseases
it's a research usually however there is
a very promising
future of using next generation
sequencing to diagnose other not just
aquatic infectious diseases but chronic
diseases as well
and what are the challenges uh it's not
an easy road
definitely to use next generation
sequencing in the everyday clinical
setting and husker
systems definitely one of the biggest
challenge i believe everybody in this
field agree with me
is standardization using negative and
positive control standard way
the clinical validations can be
challenging and accuracy and
replicability
there are regulatory challenges and of
course infrastructure
that can that needs to support this kind
of technology
but we are not alone on this field and i
think it's really great to see that
many companies took up the challenge to
use tax generation sequencing
and use this technology in the
infectious disease space
so we are moving forward and hopefully
we can see many more implications and
use cases where you can use
next generation sequencing in the
infectious disease
diagnostic space so what we do at
bioshock we do
rapid precision infectious disease
diagnostic by
using artificial intelligence and next
generation
sequencing for environmental
surveillance and rapid precision
diagnostics
for infectious diseases we can
detect and identify the pathogens within
a very short
and quick turnaround time and we can
also identify
virulence factor and antimicrobial
resistance to guide the optimal
precision
therapeutics for the patients with that
bioshock and improves patient outcomes
and decreased
health care costs so and i just brought
a couple of
example from last year's uh where we
have been
doing hospital acquired infection
monitoring
on hospital surfaces and also clinical
metagenomics
with these collaborators and i just want
to share
some of the results so we work together
with burma grad international hospital
which is
like an international destination
hospital in southeast
asia they see more than one million
patients annually so this is an
incredible space
for microbes and we were able to set up
a
pilot study to screen a thousand
patients and collecting urine samples
what we did we sequenced these durian
samples actually we trained the hospital
to do their own sequencing and then they
uploaded the
clinical the clinical information and
the genetic information and we were able
to provide
them clinical microbiology reports so
here you can see an example of our
clinical macrobiology report
with patient information and ordering
information but also like tracking
the problem like what kind of pathogens
were detected in the urine
so what we learned during some of the
uh studies we have been doing for
example with the new jersey hospital
um that like physicians usually have
only
30 seconds from one patient to another
to make a definitive diagnosis
and for that if we provide them a
comprehensive report on all the
identified pathogens the drug resistance
that can overwhelm
them and this report cannot be used
efficiently
so we try to tailor it as a
clinician-friendly wave to provide as
much information as possible
and we usually highlight the high
virulence high resistance but to change
to have the physicians guide their
therapy
and on the left side and i really like
to highlight that but you can get from a
high throughput sequencing technology
is that like you can see the whole
comprehensive microbiome profile
so on the left you can see a healthy
microbiome profile on the top
and you can see that there is a diver's
macrobiome in a healthy
person and on the down you can see a
urine profile indicating there is an
overgrowth of e coli bacteria so
even if the first patient the healthy
one you can detect e-coli you can see
there is a healthy microbiome harvard
when there is an overgrowth of one
bacteria for example
that can direct the physicians and let
them know that this is the case where
you need to treat
this patient when they have symptoms and
you can get the pathogen information the
virulence factor and also the resistance
to better help and provide like
precision
uh infectious disease diagnostics and
therapy
so some of our additional data from this
pilot and these are like just only for
the first uh
150 samples that were processed and we
are in
the process to finalizing all our
results but of course with metagenomics
we found the more
diverse macrobiome we were identif we
were able to identify 172 species
compared to culturing which is a
targeted methodology
and also we were really happy to see
that the validation was like the high
agreement
in both cases the dominance of e coli
was consistent and that was also
consistent with previous
clinical studies that shows that e coli
is highly linked to urinary tract
infections so and i just want to
drive your attention for one particular
case
and and those are like all the culture
negative samples
so what we found with the culturing on
these exact same samples which went
through
next generation sequencing that 30
percent of the culture
results were negative and out of those
microbes were detected with sequencing
around 80 percent and out of those 40
percent
were pathogens so that means that those
are the use cases where net generation
sequencing can actually
give you a final definitive answer on
the quarter gene detection
we also looked into the drug resistance
markers and we identified most of the
drug resistance were linked to e coli
it's also because of the high prevalence
of e coli
species detected in the samples and we
looked into the multi-drug resistance
pathogens that were mostly e coli
sodimonas and endothelial cocco species
and we were able to identify many of the
drug
classes that these pathogens were
resistant to this high resistance was
uh probably due to this hospital is uh
the samples were collected in hospitals
so these patients were hospitalized with
a high resistance rate
another exciting pilot which uh we took
up the challenge to use next generation
sequencing
was uh last year working together uh
with a new jersey hospital and health
care system where they
where they identify that there was an
evidence
of high drug resistance
uh not just for medicine that was seen
in staphylococcus auroras
but when they shifted to prescribing a
different drugs uh
through metoprene supramethoxazole they
found that there might be a resistance
to both drugs so
they sent us isolates and we used next
generation sequencing to identify these
strains
um and indeed what we found that there
was an
evidence for both drug resistance and we
also additionally
found that in two thirds of these
samples mupirosen
resistance was found that means that uh
um that's very alarming because that's
for example an antibiotic that's used on
the skin for decolonization before
surgery
so these pathogens are quickly can be
resistant uh based on the
therapy and prophylaxis that has been
used that's why it's so
important to use precision infectious
disease
therapy that means that we treat exactly
that pathogen that can be detected in
the patient
so and again just to highlight with a
couple of numbers uh
what i said uh it's quite shocking that
currently empirical antibiotics that
means that we
use antibiotics for the patients
based on population based studies
that means that 91 percent we use
empirical antibiotics for the patients
and only using clinical metagenomics and
sequencing that could decrease
uh the unnecessary days of antibiotic
therapy and decrease
the antimicrobial resistance if we if we
use this novel technology
so if you have time right now i
recommend to watch the resistance
fighters it's a great documentary
on anti-microbial resistance and the
global crisis uh
crisis uh we have been facing currently
and
last year the cdc uh has been alerting
and alarming uh this very important case
uh
to work against anti-microbial
resistance so bioshock is also
part of this effort to decrease
antimicrobial resistance and work again
work with anti-macrobio stewardship
so but everybody's companies and
everybody is focusing on
shifted to kobit 19 pandemic and so
today i saved a little time to talk
about that and how next-generation
sequencing this
emerging technology can be used and why
is it
important to use uh during the pandemic
so
i don't want to talk much details about
the virus i'm sure everybody is
monitoring
uh the state this is a
picture from april 16 from john hopkins
um
website where they're showing we are
over two million people
that were diagnosed with coping 19 and
we are reaching 150 000
patients who died from kobe 19
around the world how you can use
sequencing and why is it important
as implication for public health
intervention
genome sequencing in viral outbreaks
is desire desirable to characterize the
infectious agents
determine its evolutionary rate identify
the signature of host adaptation
track transmission route identify
monitor diagnostic targets
and characterize the responses to
vaccines and treatment that's incredibly
important
and also to determine the role of
co-infections when we do comprehensive
metagenomics so this is just an example
how all the collaborators got together
and have been
sequencing what is uh samples
and upload data to
a server where we can analyze of
variants and mutation rates and track
the spread of the virus identify
clusters and transmissions so we can
learn more about the virus spreading
and also like
by countries you can see the colors
differently um
for example where what's the origin
of the virus which was identified
from patient samples so this is a great
website to follow
gis aid um there is a great
collaboration and it's incredible how
globally all the researchers came
together to track the virus using
sequencing
also i would like to highlight the
effort of the center for
disease control and prevention there are
currently
around 37 manufacturers and commercial
laboratories that have
an in vitro diagnostics euea and that
means that like they
implemented the new diagnostic tool to
to use
against kobe 19 and i think this is very
very critical
because we need to do as much screening
and diagnostic as possible
to monitor the virus
what we do at bioshock we have a
provisional
clear permit new york state permit we
have active irb to process samples using
sequencing
we have a bsr2 high complexity
laboratory and they have an incredible
scientist
moroccoto rodriguez she has been working
in the front line
for the supporting the validation
optimization of all these new
technologies
um we try and in the future we have the
possibility to implement screening tests
such as the lamp system um that was
validated by cornell
and the pcr based technologies such as
bio fire firm array
um and also still our focus is on the
next generation sequencing
which can step up and have in the
diagnostics so
currently we do clinical validation in a
target enrichment essay
in partnership with the bioscience
company and using our
bioshock ovdx software to translate
all these genetic information
immediately
into a clinical report which can help
the physicians
but also using all the sequencing data
we can provide the research use only
uh documentation about uh additional
information on the streaming so how this
happen
we collect human and environmental
samples we do
again the microbial extraction library
preparation and next generation
sequencing
and use our software uh the bioshock dx
for the comprehensive
evaluation and bioshock vdx for
cloud-based software
technology and provide a clinical
microbiology report
and this sequencing can additionally
besides identification of the streams
can add information about virulence
factors and geographic sources
and i think what can be interesting when
we increase our database
in the future using artificial
intelligence
we can stratify risk and outcome
we can predict the outcome using
additional clinical metadata
so what's going to happen during the
next
couple of months this paper was
published this week
in april 2020
it predicts that there are going to be
recurrent outbreaks
and interventions are definitely needed
specifically to improve critical care
develop effective therapeutics
and social distancing definitely can be
a key
so again i just want to highlight we
need to do as much as possible
screening diagnostic and sterological
testing
and we need to use the next generation
sequencing for surveillance
this is just an example startup company
i have been working with to focus and
deploy
um rapidly floodable
rapidly deployable affordable containers
technologies uh
and they can place molecular diagnostic
or just sample collection
um centers to anywhere
and also it's really great to see the
collaborations and how
innovators are adopting new technologies
to fight against kobe 19.
so some of the example is like hand
hygiene tools
uh these infection tools have been on
the market uh
trying to get euas to use it and
implement it into the critical care
um and also there are some techie apps
using ai for example for carb detections
and body temperature detection using
drones
and cameras so there is a very exciting
time for digital house and
innovators besides these very crucial
challenges
and with that said i would like to
finish my presentation
i would like to thank my bioshock team
who has been like really incredible
during this very difficult time
um and also i would like to thank for
each and every first responders who are
fighting
against uh despondent and uh saving
lives every minute and they are in the
front line risking their lives um
so with that said i would like to just
emphasize stay at home
stop the spread and with that you can be
also a coed
19 hero and save lives thank you so much